[Music]
if there was an expectation that a trial
in minneapolis would represent a turning
point for america
well come to a place like this and it's
clear how huge the challenges are
there is a stark hopelessness in these
suburbs of baltimore
poverty hunger addiction
and a history of confrontations with the
police where the suspect ends up dead
people like freddie gray arrested in
2015
for possessing a knife he died in the
back of a police van
no one was convicted and the city
erupted
freddie gray was dead before he ever got
into that police wagon
he was born into a living condition that
is not set up for him
to make it past the age of 25. kwame
rose is an activist who says police
brutality is only the end of a path
through a broken society america as we
know it was set up on the oppression
the enslavement the murder the rape of
black people
right we need to abolish police
communities can police themselves right
can they though yeah the reason crime is
prevalent in sandtown winchester
is because there's no grocery store
within miles of that place
but there's liquor stores right there's
no jobs but there's dope
there's dope stashes right those who
found opportunity have long since
abandoned this place
and yet it is still home for so many
trapped in a poverty
that is here overwhelmingly black
on a street corner we met steve he'd
approached us to find out what we were
up to
and we got talking how hard is it being
a dad
in a neighborhood like this it's hard
because when you try to live
and pay bills and also make your kids
happy
it's hard it's hard it's a struggle
and i don't get an education from school
mine came from prison
what we're in prison for attempt murder
sell different things i've been home
almost 15 years
i'm still home i'm a good person keep
coming
keep coming that's good right there
up the road jc falk runs a food bank
it's his way of trying bottom up
to fix the system i spent 30 years of my
life trying to end racism and it's
miserable it's a miserable life
because i would have never ended racism
and so now i've shifted my
my view and i'm trying to end the things
that
get fuel racism that fuel oppression and
marginalization of people one is food
if i can give somebody food that's
hungry then i take away one of the
pillars that
gives racism power my brother tyrone
west
he was a hard-working man he was a
church man
tawanda jones lost her brother in a
confrontation with police on these
streets back in 2013
again no conviction instead it was
decided he died from bad health
and hot weather during the struggle the
systemic racism
and until we get to that till we weed
that out
till we read that or we're going to be
back and start and how do you weed that
out
how you waited out to me is knocking it
down building the back up
unfortunately it's a revelation i'm
sorry like
and i never used to talk like this i'm
always big on
reform changing but nothing has changed
it's getting
worse against the wishes of the governor
here the state has gone further than
any other in the country and pushing
through sweeping
police reforms it is a moment certainly
accountability for the police but it is
also so clear
that this goes well beyond police
brutality
walk these streets spend time with the
people here
and it's clear this land of opportunity
is cruelly selective
mark stone sky news in baltimore